what a journey this has been for you how
are you feeling I mean are you shocked
are you surprised I'm not I knew it was
coming soon every time we came out on
this dance floor I gave it my all
I have no regrets I really did I left it
all out here on the floor and every
dance was special every dance I was
present and this guy you know like I
said I never throw it for life and he's
got this so much coming out of dance he
also taught me a lot about life and that
woman I was searching for when I first
arrived here I found her what is the
biggest takeaway from this experience
the new me a fresh start sharing things
with the world that I have always kept
inside and it feels good I feel lighter
do you yeah I do I'm gonna miss
everybody but I but the process of this
whole play it's a dance competition play
it was so much more than that
did you ever surprise yourself were you
ever surprised by her absolutely not I
mean she when she came in she could
knock danced a single thing and now you
know doing these dances that she's been
doing it's incredible it really is what
are you gonna miss most about Sasha
seeing him on a daily basis just his
sense of humor I'm not gonna miss him
scaring me certainly not gonna miss
those jumping out of trees and in my car
and things like that but just his
presence everyday
honestly just his presence that voice
you were very open today about your
divorce we had never heard about this
before why was now the time to open up
about that publicly because they had a
platform to do it and I had been talking
about all my struggles all my struggles
and I was just very general and it was
kind of like I wanted to share with the
people because a lot of people who have
gone through that many and I was dancing
and hoping to inspire women that was
kind of my group that I was focused on
and I hope that I helped someone out
there tonight just by sharing my story
I'm sure you did now you have some free
time are you gonna get back into the
dating pool you've a lot to offer
I will see you when it's ready if
someone comes with but you're open to it
I am open to it of course
[Music]